[Music]
yeah
so I think I was introduced so I don't
but I'm Robert kwit from national public
radio and from Radio
Lab
uh I should warn you in advance that
what I know about mathematics higher
mathematics is very very little which is
the excitement to me about trying to do
this this is for me would be is trapes
work so um let me introduce the guests
uh first known as the math guy on
National Public Radio he is the author
of 30 books and over 80 published
research articles Keith develin is a
recognized mathematician a recognized
mathematician which I guess means that
he's really a plumber and looks like a
mathematician or I don't know and a a
researcher at Stanford University and
here is
Keith and next Jonathan Bourne is a
mathematics professor at the University
of Newcastle in Australia he's the
director of the center for computer
assisted research mathematics and its
applications you kind of know when they
do that there's got to be some acronym
it's called karma so uh he's a noted
expert on the number pi and a leading
thinker in the field of experimental
mathematics so here is
Jonathan next Marcus totoy a professor
of mathematics at the University of
Oxford a mathematician a researcher
occasionally on Radio Lab he studies
prime numbers and symmetry mark
[Music]
and finally a science journalist
producer with a PhD in particle physics
Simon sing's documentary about Fermat's
Last Theorem was nominated for an Emmy
his publication on the same subject
Fermat's Enigma was the first book about
mathematics to become the number one
bestseller in the UK here is
Simon
well let's see how to start this first
of all since the question posed is what
is
mathematics there uh you I just I don't
know way of describing nature art form
language brains wave seeing the world
exploration competitive sport God's mind
revealed uh let's start with a with a
pattern sense when you were a kid did
you take an unusually long gazes at
pineapple surfaces
or sunflower no it took me a long while
actually to get into maths I didn't uh
or or math as you call it here yes we
keep it singular I don't know why I
think it's a very plural subject but we
call it mathematics but yeah maybe
mathematics is a better way to um but it
was around uh you know because I think
the real distinction here is that early
on you your career you're doing dealing
with numeracy and arithmetic and that's
not what mathematics is about and I
think for many people that's the
misconception they think it's they say
they're bad at maths but actually they
may be bad at numeracy most
mathematicians are bad at arithmetic um
uh and actually Matt is about pattern
searching it's and it's what we've been
evolutionary programmed to do you know
we've survived in this world because
we're very good at spotting patterns um
in the jungle if you see something with
a bit of symmetry it's likely to be uh
an animal which either you could eat or
it might eat you so it's good to
recognize symmetry so when you were
seven like did you go to the out into
the garden and say one ant two ant four
an no no no I was actually much more
interested in languages um I I wanted to
become a spy and be in the foreign
office um and it was only when I started
to realize that mathematics is actually
actually I hated languages because they
all these irregular verbs and strange
spellings and it was when I suddenly
realized mathematics is a fantastic
language it has no exceptions got lots
of surprises but it's got no regular
verbs and it's a fantastic language for
describing the world around you and I
think it was about 1213 that I started
to get little bit nerdier and start to
spot spirals in pineapples but that did
happen yeah it did and I I now can't
look at a pineapple without going oh
eight
13 and you did when did you happen to be
uh pattern sensitive not at all no I I
the year before I went to high school
back in England was the year the
Russians put Sputnik in I only to go
into the Space Race I mean it was just
space exploration I wanted to do physics
and so I started learning mathematics in
order to become a good physicist and I
didn't like mathematics until I was 16
and I met calculus anyone who's read the
blog I put up on the on the world
Science Festival blog I put a Blog up
about why I became a mathematician the
very moment where all my classmates got
turned off calculus that turned me on
first of all it was obviously was going
it was obviously important for getting
Rockets into space and getting them back
again but it was also very powerful and
I couldn't understand it it's the first
thing you meet at school that you
actually can't understand if you put
your mind to it it Baff me it was clear
that there was a mystery I mean we're
talking this was a mystery that you felt
personally you wanted to solve I I
couldn't stand I was a kind of kid that
used to take the automobiles apart I
wanted to see how things worked and here
was this calculus that was invented by a
guy was aged 22 because the college was
closed you know he was going to go to
Isaac Newton was go to Cambridge there
was the plague what are you a Newton fan
or okay and you know yeah what would you
do if the college was closed you'd
probably go and have a good time and go
to the beach Isaac Newton invents
calculus so you've got this 22y old
invents calculus it's powerful I could
use it I could do all the problems and
get them right I had no idea why it
worked and I wanted to take the hood off
figure out so that's that's maybe so
when you played sports did you think
okay if I stand Here The Arc of the the
declining I think are were you odd or
were you what I would call ordinary no I
was never enough of a sportsman to do
anything except say I wish it goes
somewhere
else please let somebody else catch it
um my uh my father's quite a
distinguished mathematician he's been
president of Canadian mathematical
society and I think he's now the sixth
oldest member of the London mathematical
Society in his L oldest well they keep a
list it's a little bit because it's the
mathematics Society you figure indeed
indeed and you can win a priz you can
win a prize but only once for being the
oldest person at an American math
Society banquet really you can't keep
doing it for obvious
reasons well wait wa you can't they have
annual Banquets and you like they do
they do and to get back to your a
central no wait wait why if you're 93
can't you make it to your 94th because
they want to give somebody else younger
a chance oh so you're not invited to the
bank you can come but you can't win the
prize again okay and and since the
oldest um uh viene um Austrian
mathematician some years ago was via
Taurus who was also the oldest Austrian
and died about age 108 you can see that
you wouldn't want to give this eyes out
only once every 20 years but getting
back to your central question I also
just want such strange Envy so these
people in Britain are going to this
dinner envying the Australian is two
years older than me I don't know well
people do lie about their age in the
opposite direction after while right
yeah quite they try to say they're older
um I I since my dad was a mathematician
he taught me a few pieces of math to Pro
to win bets with faculty in C Andrew so
he taught me to solve 2 by two
simultaneous equations when I was six I
you have like that well because he won 5
he won 5 pounds of cheese and a 5 pound
note which was quite a lot in the 50s no
he did but if you if you're a
six-year-old using whatever you just
said in a betting situation with
six-year-old I don't see how that would
be an occasion that would ever come up
well I suppose I must have liked the
pattern because I had no idea what I was
doing but after that I went to
University to study history and I got as
far in the days of punch cards for
registration of being about to drop my
cards in second year into a history box
and I thought if I do this in 10 years
years's time I won't be able to
integrate anything or work out the
equations of motion but if I go back and
find the math cards in five years time I
can still read about the Treaty of
Vienna I did and it's turned out to be
the truest decision I ever made so I can
tell you the day I became a
mathematician but I came to it a bit
like it sounds like you out of the Arts
not out of the Sciences directly well so
so then what is it exactly is it is it
an instinct that humans are born with I
mean there are there are people in the
Amazon who have one and two and three
but they don't have four five or six or
seven and they do perfectly well I mean
they seem to know the difference between
more and less I don't know what they do
if I had three fish and you had two
apples and I wanted to raise the price
of fish I don't know idea how that
conversation would go but do you think
it's an instinct in us I don't know you
I um I I I I don't think it's an
instinct in in the way that we think
about math too when we think about
numbers and precision um you can do
experiments I think there experiment
with a raven where a raven uh was uh on
the top of a tower and a hunter would
approach the Tower and the Raven would
disappear and the Raven would would
disappear until the hunter had left the
tower and gone away again and then the
the the hunters thought well how clever
is this raven so then two Hunters would
go in the tower Raven would disappear
one Hunter would leave but the cow the
Raven wouldn't return turn until the
second Hunter had left so so the raven
could somehow count but if five Hunters
went in and four came out then the Raven
couldn't differentiate between five and
four it would come back and get shot by
the remaining Hunter so so it's as
though it's an approximate yeah it's as
though Hunters were like uh tablespoons
of of sugar and I can differentiate
between two spoonfuls of sugar and one
spoonful of sugar in a pile but I can't
really differentiate between five and
four so unless we can begin to put
symbols or words to numbers then it's
only then I I think that we can begin to
really manipulate them I should just
stress I I of the people here on the
panel I like everybody here I didn't
really like Matt as a child and I didn't
really like it as an adult either no
really no I mean I be like um like like
Keith I was interested in science I it's
a very obvious desire to want understand
the universe to understand where the
universe came from what stuff's made of
where life came from this is really
obvious stuff to be interested in I
think nearly all children are interested
in that and then gradually we maybe lose
that Curiosity um but to be interested
in math is a bit odd and and and I think
that's why why people are sometimes
scared of math or don't understand why
math is a passion I only became
interested in math because then as as a
scientist I became a science journalist
as a science journalist I ended up
writing about maths and I'd always seen
maths as something you have in order to
do science but I think that's how it's
that's how it started of course you know
in order to navigate the World um to
measure land areas to tax them to build
new buildings you find or to answer
these big questions of science you find
that maths is the best language and then
it starts to take on a life of its own
and you start to get interested it for
in it for for its own sake and the the
properties of numbers and and the
patterns there is it is it a measuring
thing like if if if a girls were going
to jump rope so it's just basically one
you know they they have those
patterns I'm not a girl so I don't know
but uh I don't know why I say things
like that um but I isn't isn't singing
dancing and playing games sort of
playing with segments of time a lot and
so isn't that math sort of so
mathematics really change the the the
elementary parts of mathematics is Stu
that everyone would have had in school
that does come out of the world it's
sort of formalizing ways of thinking
that we used to survive and have done
for the history of humankind but then
put the moment when I got into it at
calculus it sort of flips it becomes
largely something we invent and create
ourselves becomes very abstract it's
still actually useful but it doesn't I
mean in calcus you're talking about
infinite decimals there are no infinite
decimals in the world we invent them in
part to understand the world but those
of us that are in mathematics play with
them because they're fun to play with
yeah they really
are trust me well the the audience
probably knows it's certainly what the
encyclopedists thought that uh while
French was a perfectly good language for
science only German was really set for
emotion and love
uh these are things that people think
about other languages but the reason I
bring it up is that what has kept me
attracted to mathematics it's two things
it's all of what Keith said this
wonderful set of tools unreasonably
efficacious tools uh for making more
progress often than seems reasonable but
at the same time it's a language in
which you can express things you didn't
know you wanted to express until you
could speak some of the language so the
language is called numbers I guess the
language is called mathematics numbers
are some of the words because I I do I
remember reading somewhere that a baby
born on the first day if you stood in
front of them on the first day of its
life and you went beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep for a very long time
and then you changed oh only up to three
yeah and if you change the number the
baby startles or looks more closely so
there there's some sense of of pattern
anyway but now the the
number
um have any idea when that that was
invented or where that comes from how
old it is well yes it's interesting you
can even do some fairly robust kind of
cladistics and you'll discover that the
number two is older than the number one
in terms of where it's shared in the
tree of language really yeah so you you
know it's all conjectural that's the
lovely thing about uh archaeology and
paleo whatever you're never going to be
proved wrong but it seems pretty
plausible that we well that's a good
thing isn't it well these very ancient
Bones the like the asango bone which is
tens of thousands of years old with
notches you know people keeping track of
things and wanting to know how many I
mean it's not quite clear what it's
keeping track of whether it's um uh
perhaps a calendar or something but you
know I think you know navigate seeing
patterns in the stars is probably where
you know you start to get ma the
mathematical mind working the fact that
things repeat themselves and if they
repeat themselves and you can make
predictions about the future and this
language gives you incredible power and
and you know you've seen that predict a
flood or Eclipse yeah when the flooding
of the they spotted patterns to this and
there that that that math once you've
had the flooding of the Nile not only
you want not only do you want to be able
to predict the flooding of the Nile you
then want to be able to to rebuild your
Fields afterwards you need to have
measurement and and geometry be able to
do this so it's a purely functional
useful tool that the sociey need if
we're going to trade if we're going to
send ships we're going to PL if we're
going to be interested in astrology we
need mathematics but the the the really
interesting transition and I think what
was interesting about the little video
clip we had at the beginning was a lot
of that was Applied Mathematics and it's
verging on the science and we kind of
all understand why science is
interesting useful and important but but
the really weird transition I'm not sure
when this happens this is maybe going
back two and a half thousand years is
people who begin to study numbers purely
for the hell of it for the fun of it for
the surprisingness the fact that there's
this thing called a perfect number six
uh one
plus 2+ 3 is six and 1 and two and three
are the only numbers that go into six
and 28 is uh 1 4 7 and 14 am I missing
one and two add up to 28 and a divis the
28 but then I don't know where the next
one is up in the hundreds isn't it 496
yeah so so so per so now do you think
that these people do you think these
people sort of did you have to get
because I'm actually wondering whether
you get notches first or maybe circles
you think circles or lines precede
numbers or circles lines or triangles
numbers abstract numbers are incredibly
recent was about 10,000 years ago almost
and it was essentially money in Sumeria
Sumerian society reached a stage of
complexity where the trading was
obviously much better if it was mediated
by something and basically if you want
to know where numbers do it's like
following political careers find where
the money comes from that's where the
numbers came from nothing new in the
world especially and geometry as well I
mean you see in in the uh Papyrus you
see a formula for the volume of a
pyramid and beautifully proved as well
using sort of an early form of the
calculus well of course that was a
practical need to know you know how many
stones are we going to have in this
pyramid but but then you see a sort of
abstract love of the mathematics and the
game starting to come in and it takes on
a sort of power of its own and I think
that's right these perfect numbers are
are perfectly useless perfectly
pointless perfectly useful but you kind
of think that's kind of cool these are
where are the other are you imagining
that this is cu you're sort of like the
like you is this like a a prayer that
you're telling us here or is this
history that you could I we're not going
to meet Mr Cav this is history and I
think it's interesting to ask how much
of it is uh contingent and how much of
it was necessary so for example usual
accounting would be that the Greeks
class the classic Greeks brought us the
sense of trying to build a deductive
system being interested in the
properties of numbers for their own
right or mixed with ideas of Harmony and
religion but imagine and I I've just
been some work with my colleague David
Bailey at Lawrence Berkeley labs and was
flabbergasted to discover 13 decimal
accuracy square roots in very old Indian
documents pre
Christian um so sophisticated that you
wonder what would have happened if those
techniques had made it to the west
through Spain in 700 AD not in 1400 ad
and for some reason all of the
manuscripts that we learned about
Aristotle or Pythagoras had actually got
burnt and so what we had inherited was a
very much more
functional set of how to do things is it
necessary that we would have later said
we need Theory I'm not so sure but Keith
is positing the the that the first guy
was just a businessman on The Fast Track
and he just got himself a first attache
case or something right the other way to
think of it would be that the first
mathematician was sort of an artist like
you would think maybe like he just
wanted to play mat goes back so so far
in time time that we had to feed
ourselves we had to keep warm we had to
fight off bears and wolves and and math
evolved in that environment where you
desperately needed to survive and and
and it's the same with science I thought
you were the artist guy I thought you
were trying to imagine this uh fellow
who was playing yeah but there's yeah
but but I think math starts off as being
functional science starts off science
doesn't start off you have technology
and then people start realizing if they
want to build technology it's actually
quite useful to understand some of the
basic science so so so the pur side
emerges only much later the great um
Canadian geometer coxeter was a friend
of eers the Dutch artist who most people
who come to these sort of things I think
probably likes um and um Laton his life
Co coxer lived a very long life lived
through age 97 and gave lectures till
about age 96 um good lectures he um
wrote a paper maybe one of his really
last papers and he's explaining one
ofer's uh continuing constructions and
he said eer did this as art I had to use
trigonometry huh so I I think there are
there are artsy phrases that you
associate there are things like elegant
proofs and ugly proofs words it's like
that the way it it feels to me a little
bit is that is that art is just Freer it
it that the real art means if you paint
a painting you're not constrained you
can no but most artists will disagree
with you and say that they best creative
art art is done under huge constraints I
mean Stravinsky used to say that he was
only creative when he put constraints on
himself so I think if you have too much
freedom very often you become uncreative
and Mathematics is an incredibly
creative subject we're making a lot of
choices in the sort of things we want to
celebrate as theorems I'll talk about in
a seminar or write up in a in a paper I
mean I I study the world of symmetry I
can get a computer just to generate
arbitrarily new symmetrical objects um
what's interesting is to choose the ones
which have something special about them
and it's just the same you can get a
computer to turn out music but you make
a choice as a composer and I think
there's an incredibly creative side to
well why is this exciting there's an
exciting connection with another bit of
mathematics which is totally unexpected
and this is why I want to tell you this
story so I think there is a lot of
choice in mathematics one nice
description of of the aesthetic response
is the perception of order in what seems
first to be chaotic yeah and again that
calls on whether it's a Fugue or a
structured piece of poetry to have that
underlying structure and that to some
degree the aesthetic response the AHA
equivalent to an aha mathematically as
we say oh okay it does make sense it's
not just Jangles yeah but here's a
difference if if we all agree that this
will be the number three let's all agree
we all agree that this symbol will mean
we're going to add something yeah once
we've agreed on those terms three Means
A tripet Triplet of some sort and plus
means then if you then if I say 3 +
three equals it at that point it has to
be six that's not the case for
Shakespeare Hamlet could have killed his
father anytime Bill Shakespeare you're
comparing two things which are not alike
it's like talking about English grammar
this this word is spelled like this in
the hum only but you know mathematics is
not about spelling and grammar it's
about the big stories um the stories of
prime numbers of symmetry these are the
things that we the stories we choose to
celebrate and and they they have a truth
about them you can't change them there
so it feels like there's more
constraints on mathematics but still the
stories we choose to tell are as
exciting and have the drama and we we
choose to tell those stories because
they have the same effect on us as a
piece of Shakespeare you're just
comparing two wrong things then no not
exactly because uh I feel if I wanted to
have like the Chinese menu all time I
know that as soon as I got 3 plus three
I don't I I'm not allowed to turn it
into seven where if I'm no no exactly
but if You' got Hamlet you'll say well
I'm going to spell it h a m l e t and
then if you have it later on in the play
and you misspell it it's sort of that's
uninteresting that's not what
Shakespeare is about mathematics isn't
very very
aggressive very element math with very
elementary math it's D it's dry it's
ugly it's tedious just like very ugly
prosaic English that the jump you have
with the spoken word is from the spoken
functional word to poetry and sudden you
say wow that's that's beautiful that
that's something I want I want to
embrace that's something I want to play
with I want to create surprise I want to
make people laugh and and with math
again you have these very mundane praic
numbers and you ask very basic questions
like multiplication and square roots and
uh and you say well what happens if I
take away three from six well that's
three that's pretty obvious what about
if I take away six from three hey that's
mindblowing the first person to ask that
question suddenly has to invent the idea
of negative numbers and this this I
can't hold negative3 Pebbles this is
that's mind BL and then you start saying
well okay sare root of 9 is three what
about the sare root of -3 what does that
mean and that becomes curious and odd
and then you say well okay let's allow
that to be a number and we'll call that
uh root threei is that right good thank
you um I'm just thinking this like is
that I don't want to push this too hard
I think you guys are of the you you
you'll say one an odd number plus one
another odd number makes an even number
and that like shocks you and it's like
story Stelling in a way it it doesn't it
doesn't chock me and and you're at the
heart oh you find it beautiful you're at
the heart of something really
complicated but I could say all of
computer science really originated when
George buou said No 1 plus 1 doesn't
equal two it equals
zero who said that George Bo when you go
back to the basis of the idea that you
might be adding in what's called clock
notation or binary and the effect of
21's is a zero and that gives you the
whole ideas as a modern modular
arithmetic what are called finite fields
and on and so the creativity of math
comes is to say not that it was wrong to
say 1+ 1 equals 2 but there may be
interesting ways of abstracting this
where it's better to think of it as
being something else and so again we
don't try and say if you've got a
dictionary you can write Shakespeare we
do try to say if you've learned the
language you probably appreciate some of
the Shakespeare well let me switch the
question a little bit let me why are
some people better at this than others
is this um is this a talent is it gentic
is it just a language with different
degrees of difficulty
or interest it's just interest if you're
interested you'll become good at it and
you do it I mean two of these guys
didn't even begin in mathematics I
didn't begin I began in physics and not
mathematics and one is
denying but we all enjoy it and we
appreciate it and it's just a matter of
interest that that I think there is a
there's a there is a reason why
mathematics um people do seem to be
sometimes bad at it which is mathematics
is a bit like building a pyramid and
each year you add more to the pyramid if
you have one bad year in your
mathematical education it's impossible
to build anything on it you're lost from
there on inwards and that doesn't happen
so much in other subjects you know if
you if youve got a bad history teacher
um teaching the victorians it doesn't
kind of mess you up for the history of
the 20th century you can get back into
it a little bit like you said um with
your experience of well I can uh reread
the history later on but with the maths
if I miss out so I think that what
happens is that you need to have a very
consistent um education because one bad
layer and and it really messes you for
the rest of the story well is the key
thing when you say it's interest is it
is it that you're like the problem with
math as opposed to some other subjects
is that there is a right answer so you
you if you're learning you know it's
hard to fa yeah often so so it's hard to
you you're just going to fail or succeed
it's sort of
binary I me that's one of its chunks I
think actually yeah there are sort of
right answers but that's not what
mathematics isn't really about what's
right it's why is something right or
wrong it's the why that's of Interest
not whether it's right or wrong that's a
a Fallout from the way we often teach it
that it's all about right and wrong
there's a right and wrongness there just
like there's a right and wrong way to
spell things but Shakespeare Isn't So to
go back to the example isn't about how
you spell the words it's is it a good
story and why do people behave the way
they do in mathematics it's not what's
right and what's wrong but why is this
right in this circumstance or then maybe
the difference is some people make this
personal they say this is my question I
want to know the answer to put as you
did I'm interested oh yeah others of us
think I'll do what the teacher says and
you never somehow get across so it never
becomes yours do you know that's how I
passed English literature at school I
got these cliff notes and I read them
and I answered the exams and it took me
10 years to like Shakespeare after I
graduated from high school people don't
have to like math people people have a
perfect right to hate Matt and I there
are many I hate languages I'm terrible
at languages um but but there is a world
out there that people may be unaware of
and just coming back to the point Keith
Made there's a lovely problem called the
fourcc color map problem so you've got a
map and people may remember this from
from school how many colors do you need
to color a map any imaginable any
conceivable map so that no two uh
regions have the same color and for a
hundred years people knew that you
didn't need more than five but they
weren't sure whether you could get away
with four and and that's kind of a weird
interesting odd question and it's just
something that gets you think do you
need four do you need five why is it
four why is it five how how would I go
about trying to prove it so it's an odd
quirky interesting bit of playful maps
and it turned out I think it was about
in the' 70s a couple of American guys uh
apple and harken proved it and they
proved it by saying that every map can
basically be built from several thousand
other constituent maps and if you can
prove that the other thousand or so con
c maps only need four colors then all
maps only need four colors now we now
know you only need four colors but it's
not a very satisfying proof it doesn't
really give you any insight it doesn't
make you smile it doesn't you we're not
that surprised because we already kind
of knew it was four so that's an area of
math which is has been curious odd and
quirky but I think mathematicians are
still waiting for that aha moment is it
doesn't have that beauty and elegance
that something like um uclid Pro ukl had
a pro Pro about the number of that that
comes to my present passion which is I
I'm much influenced by people like Greg
chaon the complexity theorist I don't
believe that just because something has
a let's use the word beautiful fact we
don't know if there infinitely many
perfect numbers those numbers like one
and six and 28 we do know it relates to
how many primes there are of the form 2
to the N minus one but and we don't know
if there any odd perfect numbers and we
haven't known that for 2500 years that's
a problem that classic Greeks asked is
there a number like six which is the sum
of its proper divisors and is odd nobody
knows and nobody has the slightest idea
how to prove it well we grew up in a
2,000 years of post Greek uh
philosophizing about mathematics which
essentially identified truth and
provability now we've known for 100
years that's not true and it's perfectly
reasonable in my now the way I organize
the world to think that might be true CU
it's not false it wouldn't make it un
beauutiful but there's a lot of stuff
out there that we should try and work
out what we think about it and and not
everything that beautiful fact will have
a beautiful proof not everything that's
provable will have a nice proof and that
changes your view of mathematics do you
hear what you're saying like the way
you're already in love with the question
what happens in a lot of schools and
particularly in junior high schools and
high schools in America is that people
want the answers the teachers want the
answers but they never ask you to love
the question right well I think it's it
comes back to this idea actually that
very often when teaching math we just
teach the grammar and the vocabulary
although it's like learning a musical
instrument where you're only allowed to
play scales and arpeggios and nobody
ever plays your real piece of music the
reason why I fell in love with
mathematics is because my math teacher
at my my school when I was 13 pulled me
out of the math class at the end of the
lesson I thought I was in trouble he
took me around the back of the math
block I thought I was really in trouble
now um and then he said you know dooda I
think you should find out what math is
really about and he started telling me
about the Fibonacci numbers and about
primes and recommended a few books to me
suddenly I saw what this subject was
really about and I think we we cheat our
kids by by just saying oh it's about
scales and arpeggios but if you get to
listen to a piece of bark or some some
blues then you say Ah that's what I want
to do I don't know how to play that yet
I don't know how to compose it but
that's where I'm heading and that's what
I how many teachers are there like that
not enough I when I decided when I loved
calculus and want to do that's exactly
what my teachers did they took me out of
the class and said here's my college
textbooks teach yourself I'll try and
remember what it was like to do those
and help you out and it was thisly
Incredible World opened up of real
mathematics that I didn't know existed
and Simon and I were lucky I mean Marcus
and I were luy Simon wasn't I was in a
class two people got taken out I was
wondering well I'm clearly not
the it's it's um but it's it's a just a
it's a there things called uh
non-transitive dice am I nonr so if I've
got a dice and and it doesn't have one
to six on it um it's got some old
numbers on it and I give you a dice and
I give Keith a dice and typically if you
and I roll this these our own two dices
you typically beat my dice whatever
these numbers are your dice generally
are going to show a higher number than
my Dice and when you play the dice game
with Keith Keith's dice typically beats
your dice and that's the way it goes
your dice is better than my dice Keith
dice is better than yours but when I
play dice against Keith my dice beat
Keith that's a really weird thing it's
like saying that one is less than two
two is less than three but three is less
than one it's a mind-blowing concept and
then the really weird thing is if we
double our dice um the order reverses so
if you show that to a 13 14 year old kid
who's who's played with normal
arithmetic and multiplication square
roots that's a again that's a
mindblowing world well that's the other
thing that means that you want to make
it you want to attach it to the world
you want to say if you know this then
you can do that but that might be like
playing Mario Brothers it doesn't have
to somehow be like working out the
velocity of a bicycle it could just be
letting you do something you wanted to
do then you need to be a scientist I
mean I there's there's something like no
no no why can't why can't math classes I
don't know there's probably a good
answer to this but it it seems to me
that there's the two problems are that
the teacher doesn't sort of make it let
you make it personal doesn't let you
fail without punishing you for it and
third doesn't seem to make it of the
world where you live and that's because
the skills needed to do that what gets
called an educational language unpacking
concepts are a great deal more
sophisticated than the skills that are
needed to do fractions if you've just
learned enough math and we don't pay and
we don't have enough teachers ready to
come into the trenches who are secure
about their mathematical knowledge
enough that they've actually studied why
an might have a good idea by be saying
it wrong because they're just trying to
stay one step ahead and it's this
massive difference between being able to
do the arithmetic or the manipulations
and being able to step back and say ah I
see how that fits in here's they can't
have when we in most parts of the world
we put teachers in the classroom to
teach math who have very little math in
their training let me ask another
question different does does math
describe reality or is math itself out
there and and and real the answer is
yes it does both well it's both it does
both it's a j of it looks in both
directions and it legitimately looks in
both directions and that's some of its
strength well does that mean that that
math does tell you about the world but
in a more perfect way and that we live
in some sort of uh shadow of perfection
well I I'm not even sure that physics
tells us about the world physics tells
us about how the human mind conceives of
the world and Mathematics is part of
that it tells us as much about the human
mind as it does about the environment
around if you want to regard those two
things as as separate entities it's a
it's like a mirror on the mind it what
it really does is tell you how the human
mind perceives the the environment that
it's in so is it about the world that
we're in or is it about the mind the
answer is it's both but it's even better
when it's it's just turned in on itself
so you have this game you can play a
game of chess we can have some rules and
the rules of Chess allow you to have a
very beautiful
intricate game which for a thousand
years still has has entertained and
infatuated humans the game of maths
which has these basic rules like 1 plus
1 is two and so again is an infinitely
Rich Game and if you just play it around
the world of math
you end up discovering truths that that
are true forever because they're
logically consistent and it's it's a
it's a perfect game what's the greatest
thing let me just so the key thing here
is that when you do something in maths
and it's purely done in the mathematical
realm if you prove that it's true it's
true forever my brother who's also a
mathematician so I think some of this
got to do with innate abilities not uh
training because out of very different
things the three of us have all ended up
as mathematicians he said you know we
may do it better than Newton but we
don't do it writer yeah when you say
always right can you is there some uh
some thing that a mathematician
discovered that is just so beautiful and
so gigantic that it's like the super
duper best story ever told I think one
of the stories that I was told when I
was a kid which is the proof that there
are infinitely many primes uh I mean
primes they're the atoms of mathematics
they're what we build all numbers from
the indivisible numbers like 5 7 17 so
all numbers 105 is built by multiplying
3 * 5 * 7 so they're the most basic
things so um but how how many are there
of these numbers we've got 2 3 5 7 11
but maybe they're just a finite number
like the periodic table has I don't know
what it is now 118 atoms maybe there are
finitely many primes which can build all
numbers from well uclid proved with just
a beautiful little argument 2,000 years
ago ago that there'll always be more and
more primes however far you go up the
universe of numbers and he did it like
this suppose you have a finite number of
primes Suppose there are a finite number
of primes he said okay well take suppose
one of you says I don't believe you I
don't think so here's a list of all the
Primes so uid says multiply all those
primes together and then here was his
act of Genius he added one to that
number and then he says okay so this new
number that I just built you um what's
that built out of it must be built out
of some of your primes you say you've
got all the Primes well if you try and
divide by any of the primes on your list
you get remainder one because of the way
this number was built so there must be
some primes missing from your list you
haven't got them all so you say okay
well I'll just add those then nuclear
says I'll play the same trick I multiply
all those together add one and you've
still missed some lose and here's the
beauty you know Infinity does it exist
in the physical world I don't know
probably not but in the mathematical
world with this sinite little argument
that uclid made he's proved that you'll
never ever run out of these prime
numbers for me that was a magical moment
and it it's a proof which as s says
lasts forever it's it's it's it's
Eternal I physics but what's it but
what's its
Essence have you heard that proof
before yes I have okay and when you
heard it for the first time did that not
didn't did that not change yes it it did
rock your
world well I my rock is a smaller rock
than
your and then coming back to the idea
that that GH Hardy said that you know
what what the Greeks said about medicine
we laugh at what the Greeks said about
astronomy we think it's a joke but what
the Greeks said about math we still
teach it today because that mathematical
truth remains forever and
you because I asked this way I guess
you're saying hooray for the mind of a
Greek that could think that up aren't we
clever but
the I think we tapped into a
universal my implicit question was did
the numbers car if if if you got number
3 trillion
6,9 some prime way out there that Prime
is saying I knew that no it's not it's
not about how clever know these people
it's not about it's not about how clever
uid was it's about how beautiful in four
lines of argument you can G grapple with
infinity it it wouldn't have matter
whether it was UK wouldn't matter whe it
was anybody wouldn't matter whether it
was a pet cat that did it it's the idea
that that that's so precious might be
called Garfield serum yeah yeah
I think it's what distinguishes it from
The Sciences I mean we're at a science
festival and I think it's important to
distinguish that mathematics Builds on
the shoulders of giants I mean what that
proof is true and it'll be true forever
and in science it's a much more
evolutionary process you propose a model
of the world then you find it doesn't
quite fit and a new one comes over and
knocks that one out that doesn't happen
in mathematics proofs gives us this
certainty and we it allows us to to to
really stand on the shoulders of giants
and build something new so when that's
the charm of it I know that the
mathematical theorems that I proved will
last forever it's a bit of immortality
and that's why I love this subject but
but if you were to if you were to I
don't know how I asked this if you were
to become a number um are you there
whether or not we're here I mean are you
just there well I I I think I think what
you're asking is is about are we plist
at heart and I think most mathematicians
I mean I'm interested to see but I think
most mathematicians feel you know uh
3117 is a number not because the mind
thinks it is it's just a property of
that number and I certainly feel there's
a platonic reality out there called
mathematics um which is the where I
spend my time exploring this world um
and sometimes it says things about the
real world that I live in but frankly
I'm not interested in that I'm more
interested in just exploring this
extraordinary world uh which I think has
a reality of its own and when you and
when you say that is there is there is
there a castle is there like is this is
this a metaphysic which got like legs I
mean is there they're like when you like
it has structure and pattern and and
it's it's a bit like more like I think
uh uh I mean more like uh the musical
world that it's got um the same more
like a church like maybe you are
actually more religious than you maybe
you would like to admit maybe you think
that there are I suceeded Richard
Dawkins as in Oxford so I'm
definitely you say oh God no oh God yeah
but why not why if you believe that
numbers are out there whether or not
we're here if you believe there is that
logic that exists independent of all of
us and all of us that ever will be I
believe numbers are out there but I
don't believe that's true of all
mathematics I feel I'm inventing most of
the time I believe inventing or
discovering I believe I believe I don't
have any choice about discovering the
numbers and they're modern cognitive
scientists making some neurological
arguments about that but that's above my
pay scale but I don't think that all
mathematics it gets proved had to be
invented it could just have never been
done there's a link there with religion
in terms of invention of ideas and so I
won't go
there but it's it's you know these are
these are concrete IDE
well I'm I'm not the mathematician so I
I when I look at math I I look at it
with a with a purpose um when you're
looking at math you're looking at math
because of it's this game that you're
playing um it it's I think it's more
than a game though I think that you know
I think that always I always resent it
being compared to chess because it sort
of um makes it you know I think it's
more important than that well can I let
me ask a different let me ask it a
different way uh it it does it matter if
we know it's true or not like like is
there some math that's just simply undis
is there a proposition you can think of
that is permanently and totally
undecidable and therefore whether we may
not ever know it but nevertheless it may
have its existence in as soon as you
formalize what you mean by decidable the
answer is yes they are undecidable
things the things that are inarguably
true and cannot be proved really and
there are things where this is a
devastating discovery made in the 1930s
by Kurt girdle oh I've heard of this yes
devastating for made a lot of people
very nervous devastating for
philosophers but largely ignored for 50
to years you change the rules and get
around it in different ways exactly I
mean so every math problem does not have
an answer that's that's why I mentioned
the idea of odd perfect numbers we've
grown up in a culture which says if you
can ask the question and it's a
well-formed question we kind of expect
it to have an answer and probably a well
formed answer I believe there's no
reason why I'll tell you there are no
odd perfect numbers and nobody will ever
know
why say that again there are no odd
perfect numbers there's no odd number
which is the sum of its proper divisors
well how and you nobody will ever know
why so then how do you know it's true I
I have an oracle I'm telling you it's
true he's the expert he's the world
expert so we all believe but that's
religious isn't it I mean
[Laughter]
no I think you know uh girdle proved
that within first order logic which is a
the logic that we use for doing things
like number Theory uh there'll be
statements which are true which will not
be able to be proved within that system
now but actually we don't use first
order logic mostly when we do
mathematics we use second order logic
third order so I mean I think it's
oversold this so you're saying that's an
undecidable question no no he's
conjecturing it's I'm conjecturing but
certainly what we've seen in the last
few years are more and more natural
language sounding versions of what are
called girdle statements so the original
girdle statements are kind of snakes uh
swallowing their own tals imagine
imagine a a theorem that says if you
have a proof of this theorem you have a
shorter proof of its
negation yes well you start working
through it could I have a proof of it I
don't know well if you
did if you did you'd have a shorter
proof of its negation and at least
according to standard Aristotelian logic
you'd have proved something and not
something and all rules would be gone
you could prove anything so if
mathematics is consistent which we tend
to hope it is there if I could show you
that that statement if I could prove
that statement well I can't prove that
statement but I could show it's true and
this is what girdle and people after him
did but now we've even got so-called
girdle statements which seem to be
saying fairly natural things about
measurables of physical systems
are unprovable are undecidable
undecidable and we know one of the very
famous things that Paul Cohen one field
medal for um many many years 50 years
ago was uh what's called Continuum
hypothesis and it doesn't matter
precisely what it is but it asks whether
there's a set essentially is there a set
bigger than the natural numbers and
smaller than the real numbers and it's
now been shown to be independent of the
normal rules that
mathematicians are will to different
from is God three in one or just one
what's the difference well the that
doesn't bother me it bothered
Augustine that's the difference and no
no what the
difference I don't know I tell you what
the difference is and this is really
important is you haven't defined your
terms and in mathematics we're very good
at defining our terms our axioms and
what how you can deduce one thing from
another but You' just introduced
something God which uh you know you
haven't defined so we can't still start
to talk I can't prove it I can't not
prove it it's kind of a girdle like kind
of being went through his death
among other things in his notes is an
attempt to logically prove the existence
of God girdle didn't really believe what
he' done he felt that me mathematics
wasn't properly fitted
together well let's talk about you guys
what do you
do when you go to work uh do you like
sit in the chair
or like you're not like other dads you
don't go to the office I wouldn't think
or you do but maybe you don't like do
work-like behaviors
so may me ask you a different way do you
do this alone your
work have we been recorded or what I'm
not I'm getting into the anthropology of
no it is the case mathematicians at work
as my new subject how do you do it a
very famous mathematician once actually
characterize mathematics as something
that you lay down close your eyes and
work like hell and if you can say that
and mean it then you're a
mathematician and this of course means
you're doing it by yourself actually
a lot of
mathematics historically it was done
Marg by people on their own and very
often it is but these days it's
increasingly becoming a team game it is
yeah there's a lovely website uh just
started the last couple of years called
polymath MH where uh the name the fields
medalist Tim goers it came so he he he
throws out this problem on a Blog and he
just says to everybody in the math
Community or any other community if you
can contribute to trying to Sol solve
this problem add a comment and they've
solved at least one quite significant
Problem by just people throwing in ideas
and bouncing off each other and that's
almost the the opposite extreme of this
idea of the lone
genius but I still think you know your
book about Andrew WS proving firmat last
serum that was such a prize that he he D
talk to anybody else because he wanted
to be one the one to prove it and so
Andrew W is the extreme case of somebody
who uh so he was a 350 years old this is
much's last Theory that's right so he he
350 so so the more that people failed to
prove it the more it became desirable
and and when Andrew WS was based in
Princeton by that time um once he
realized the technique that might get
him there he closed shop he largely
worked at home didn't go to the
department very much he was scared that
if he whispered his process to someone
else they'd steal it from I think I
think it was partly It Was Fear of of
being beaten to the prize right two the
fear of being thought to be crazy
because if if if if no one else has done
it for 350 years why does he think he's
so smart and also just the intense Focus
that's required to take on such a major
problem and and for seven years he he
did nothing but work on this problem but
on the other roughly the same time you
have somebody like Paul aish who is an
extraordinary there a wonderful book
called The Man Who Loved only numbers
very very much worth this is the fellow
who would ring your doorbell and say I'm
open your mind I'm here for bu mind is
open and he collaborated with 500
mathematicians during his career
published over 1500 papers and uh he was
the Willie lman of math he would just
show up as the salesman go ding-dong and
he'd then spend two weeks with you and
you have to give him breakfast he he he
was here once with Ron Graham on the
east coast and they'd got up early and
all he had was two suitcases that was
the entire world possessions and he he
was with Ron Graham and and he said uh
we're stuck you know we don't know what
to do and Ron gr said it's okay I know a
guy on the west coast who can solve this
problem and they just said said well
let's ring him now and Rong gram said
look it's 8:00 a.m. in the morning in in
California it'll be 5:00 a.m. and er
said well that's great that means he'll
be
in for him it was purely mathematics and
it that's what the whole world revolved
around and and and which is the more
common way to do it by yourself or uh on
the phone or online or uh ringing the
doorbell or I I think more and more it's
uncommon to be entirely alone yeah
uncommon uncommon but I think it's a
combination I mean I find what I do best
is to to work on my own then go and
share ideas bounce and you get much
further and you come back and you need
to spend and I think there's some some
conferences right we go to conferences
we uh go and visit each other we I find
math quite difficult to do online
because uh by email because actually I
think there's a lot of unspoken sort of
uh trying to verbalize an idea in your
head and you haven't got quite got the
language there's a lot of with the my
collaborators of kind and and I can't do
that by email uh and and somehow my
collaborator yeah I think I see what
you're seeing and and then we can start
to formulate it but I would we do quite
a lot of that with Skype or or Skype
plus all right absolutely and it's
really a matter of how good the
Broadband is but if you have a problem
if you have a problem that's you know 13
pages in The figuring and you have this
fragile sort of thought in your head and
it's got all these attenuating numbers
so you go oh my God a man you're sitting
at a bar with someone and he's got his
problem which is 30 pages long I don't
quite understand how that conversation
begins because I there's a tension here
I don't want to hear about your
confusions I've got my own well I had a
I have a good friend category theorist
which uh is not my brand of mathematics
in fact the comment I was going to make
is mathematics in many ways is a single
subject but in other ways I often have
much more in common with certain parts
of physics or engineering than I have
with other parts of mathematics because
of the way I approach my subject and if
I don't happen to speak the given
subssub just hav't been taught enough
it's just as alien as if somebody's
speaking Russian and I'm trying to speak
Italian but I had a friend who was a
category theorist and his first wife
left after uh 10 years of hearing all
the category Theory anyone could hear in
10 years it didn't matter that she
didn't have any he still wanted the
audience and a lot of migs have that
experience that in the in the need to
articulate some it really doesn't matter
often if you're getting answers because
you've had to say it so much more
clearly do you guys have pencils or talk
apparently we don't have wives but
let's just keep it the pencils and chalk
do you do you work with a p do you write
something down or yeah you're trying out
sort of do you all have computers no
computers are not something that oh is
computers like uncer in this no no no it
depends on you of mathematics I think
Ian I'm at the other end I'm I'm a real
uh passion for using the computer as a
as a colleague so I'd be firing
thousands of questions and I and the
next thing I'm going to is a conference
on symbolic and numeric Computing mainly
to try and make the point that I think
we've largely restricted what we use a
computer for because of the way we were
trained and the way computers used to be
but any piece of math that I'm shown I
can usually make more progress at a
computer without it and part of it
because I can Google cuz you can Google
I can Google I mean there's an enormous
amount Google what well Google the math
literature pull out a paper from 1940 if
I know how to do it but but I think
there this kind of misconception that
the computer has kind of put the
mathematician out of business because of
course it can do arithmetic much faster
than I C but um but actually if you're
trying to explore you know these
infinitely many prime numbers well a
computer isn't much help because it's a
finite beast and it it can't have the
same sort of thought processes yet as I
do so I don't find it a very you know it
can find another big prime number but
that's not very helpful in trying to
understand the pattern that underlies
all of these prime numbers I I think all
all your questions about you know do
people work alone do they use computers
do mathematicians are no different than
anybody else at this world Science
Festival except ex I in the group we
have here in their extreme Purity in the
absolute abstractness and pointlessness
of of what is done and yet and yet every
not just every so often relentlessly
something pops up that has a major
application back in the real world uh
whether you know encryption is an
example where prime numbers are
fundamental and yet you prime you f you
study prime numbers for the hell of it
um fma's little theorem again applicable
to to to cryptography but invented by a
pure mathematician 350 years ago the
tools the community everything is the
same except the utterly utter if you
think string theory is abstract you
should think about the mathematics that
underpins it which is one last computer
question do do you know what the
computer if the if you ask the computer
so how much is the blah BL and it goes
and gives you an answer do you know how
it reached that answer sometimes the
answer is yes in principle
sometimes the answer is no but ideally
what you have is a certificate you can
have an answer that comes out and it
says and if you don't believe me check
this that's an ideal sort of answer
where you don't know how it founded but
there are many cases in which checking
an answer once you're told it is much
easier than finding it really yes and
those are the kind of cases where where
the where you feel like you've won
because not only did you get an answer
you couldn't find but you get an easy
way to check it let me ask about greguar
Pearlman Keith um
this is a very weird man he his problem
is something called the panare
conjecture what is that who is who is
GG G yes he's a very unusual case we're
going to be end we're going to be
talking about a very atypical case
although a very famous one but the
panker conjecture goes back to the
beginning of the 20th century Henry
panker and one way to think about it
was the think of the following question
you go back to to ancient Greece and the
Greeks lived on what seemed like a Flat
Earth but by using mathematics they were
able to figure out that the world was in
fact spherical and they even calculated
the diameter with great accuracy so
using mathematics you can step out of
the world you live in and see what it
must look like we didn't look at the we
didn't actually see that image of the
world we didn't know with our eyes that
it was spherical till NASA sent
spacecraft up and we took photographs
but the Greeks had figured it out by
using mathematics could we as creatures
now living in a three-dimensional world
could we understand the shape of the
universe we live in by using mathematics
so as it were step outside the universe
for example the universe may be like the
inside of a sphere and that you could
move around freely or maybe it's like
the inside of a big inner tube that you
can keep going round and around or
something more complicated like a
pretzel so there are lots of shapes the
universe might be could we figure it out
using mathematics panare came up with a
method that can be understood in those
terms and here's what pank did we've
actually got a little video we can show
about this called the conjecture because
so Perman actually was the one that
proved this 2002 so if we can roll that
tape let's imagine we want to understand
the shape of the univers is in so we're
going to get in a spacecraft and we're
going to go out and we're going to start
spaying out a rope behind us we're going
to go all around the Universe on this
tour and we're eventually going to come
back again and create a big loop that
will track the path that we've followed
so here we go round and it's a big world
it's going to take us a while to get
round we're going to come back and when
we come back we're going to be able to
find the tail that we left behind the
end of that rope and then we're going to
start to pull the Rope tight and when we
start to pull it tight one of two things
can happen you start tugging oh it
stopped maybe you're in the inside of an
inner tube and you can't pull it any
tighter or the following might happen
you pull it and pull it and pull it
and it pulls down so those are the two
possible an ways it could come about if
you can't pull it together you know that
the universe is not like the inside of a
sphere it maybe it's more like an inner
tube or something like that if you could
always if you did this infinitely many
times if you could always pull it
together the panker conjecture says then
you will be able to conclude that you
are indeed on the inside of a sphere a
three sphere if you can always do that
this is not practical in the way that
the Greeks were but it does say that
with mathematics there is no limit to
the ability of what we can find out with
Ma mathematics in principle we can find
out the shape of the universe we live in
without stepping outside of that
Universe we can look Through The Eyes Of
God if you like at our universe using
mathematics and pelman proved that in
2002 although it took seven or eight
years before the rest of the
mathematical Pro which which one did he
prove that was the that you can in fact
find the shape of the universe by going
out one things Liv uhhuh if that if you
can always put a very strange guy though
cuz he wins a prize and then he doesn't
show he didn't want the million dollar
prize he didn't want didn't want the
fields medal he's a very unusual guy
I've never met him very few
mathematicians have because he's very
reclusive uh that made it a great news
story on the other hand the mathematical
Discovery itself was the front page
story on Science magazine the the
mathematical discovery of the year was
the science Discovery the science
discovery of the year yeah I'm not so
sure it's so atypical no I don't think
it's so atypical because so what's not
so atypical
this is one of the seven Great problems
in math the year 2000 the clay
Foundation said these are the seven
Great problems for the New Millennium
that mathematicians should should think
about and the panare conjecture was one
of them and it's been the first one to
be improved by per there's a million
dollars for it and they rang up Peril
and they said he do you want the million
dollars he said no I don't do the math
for the money so then they offered him
the fields medal which is the the math
equivalent of a Nobel Prize even better
than a Nobel Prize cuz you only get it
every four years and they invited him to
Madrid Rd to collect it at the
international Congress of mathematicians
and he didn't turn up and they rang him
up and they said look why didn't you
come and get the fields Med he said I
live in Russia it would have take me a
day to fly to Madrid a day to collect
the prize a day to do the interviews a
day to fly back to Russia that's four
days wasted when I could have been doing
maths this and and airish again airish
is exactly the same I think I think
that's a very charitable description of
uh
perilman by all accounts he's a little
more strange now can I can I ask this is
a delicate question and then I'm going
to do something this this conference
this Festival doesn't usually let
questions come from the can I just I'm
really curious about this very few
people have met him and and and he is an
old CH but I would say that he that that
this absolute Purity and dedication like
erish erish won the wolf prize £50,000
but £50,000 was worth a lot and he
didn't buy a house he never never had a
house in his entire life instead he
offered the money as prizes for other
people to solve Other M I like most of
you don't know Pearlman but I I knew
Erdos quite well I first met him when I
was one and but when you were what when
I was one you remember it clearly I
don't I'll tell you the strange thing
about Pearlman though is that he stopped
doing mathematics that's where going
that is you know that is a typal totally
can I suggest that there may be just a
hint of Mr asger in the room there's a
lovely recent book I think it's called
perfect rigor perfect rigor and it is a
quintessential description of a high
achieving Ultra asger and a very very
interesting description of the sociology
of how math kids going to the Olympiad
were being trained in a POS in a time in
which there was tremendous anti-Semitism
so two places in the elite University
system for Jews a third if you got a
gold medal on the Olympiad team yeah but
the reason I said it was a typical was I
know thousands of mathematicians and
hardly any of them are like that they
regular
people I would I would hate to to to
think that as a journalist who's meets
lots of mathematicians lovely people
lots of good story but but but what I'm
saying what I'm trying to say is that
two of the greatest discoveries two of
the greatest mathematicians of of of of
our of your time your generation have
utterly utterly bizarre attitudes to the
way they live their lives and in in
science in physics and mology there are
people that are dedicated and obsessed
but not to that extreme so we're looking
at the very long end of the tale but
it's a tale that doesn't exist even in
other abstract and pure Pur wasn't
Newton you in the first world Mr Newton
fan wasn't Newton one of these guys who
would just kind of walk around get so
lost in thought he would draw things on
the path no one no one seemed to
understand anything he was saying he was
an odd duck also right yeah friend of
mine Robin Wiz told a story about
Norbert weiner the other day I don't
know if it's true but the weener family
had just moved house and and uh so he
was in his new house and he went off to
the office and they said look nor but
remember where we live remember youve
moved house so he went off to work came
back and and went back to his old house
and was sat on the doorstep really
depressed didn't know what he didn't
know where to go and this little girl
came up to me he said hey little girl uh
do you know where the weener family live
and she said yes daddy is just over here
and
it's so all right on that note I'm going
to ask if you guys want ask questions to
the panel let's see oh well we only have
5 minutes well what the hell um the
night is young yes the night is young
let's just do that now I don't know
whether they're going to turn up the
lights because this is illegal we're not
supposed to let you ask questions but
what they have to be shout so yes you'll
have to shout them but J in the front
row go ahead um and I'll repeat him I I
heard that just like U an athlete um uh
you you reach a Peak at age 27 is that
question is is athletes sometimes reach
Peak very young say 2 depends on the
sport what about what about Peak Math
years no it's
false there's a there was a great
article in the New York uh weekend
section A few years ago called uh young
Geniuses and Old Masters not about
mathematics but about art and saying
don't try and compare Picasso to Tian so
I think it's absolutely true that that
uh radical ideas tend to be the the work
of younger mathematicians and maybe if
you've not done anything Earth shaking
by the age of 35 it's unlikely you're
going to do something fantastic later
but uh there's recent book by uh Ruben
Hirsch called loving and hating
mathematics and one of the
uh the cliches that he tries to break
down is just that so I think like in any
other subject uh you don't do the same
things at 60 that you did at 20 or if
you do it's probably been wasted uh I
don't don't know very many really
creative mathematicians who say oh I'm
35 it's time to stop did aish when he
rang the bell and he was like 60 and he
was ringing the bell of a 24y old did
the 24y old go oh God the old guy or did
the guy go oh I'm so glad to see him one
night my mother called me when you were
two no I was I was you can picture this
I was 29 and I was actually naked in the
dark in bed in halex and I thought only
one person would call at this time of
the night I picked up phones of my
mother and she said somebody would like
to speak to you and little voice got in
the phone and said hello this is Paul do
you know the question with 29 Points in
the plane and it was Eros just
continuing a discussion we'd had several
years earlier actually
had he he'd had it with my brother I
realized after a while but I thought I
didn't need to dis disabuse him about
that but no he was completely
egalitarian his mind was open uh he
wasn't a mathematician of the same uh
status as the greatest mathematicians of
the 20th century but he was maybe one of
the most influential IAL cuz he went
everywhere and if I was getting a little
grouchy about comparing him to perilman
uh he was an odd
Manish Eros but he was odd in
idiosyncratic gentle ways and uh he
didn't have many needs and that's
largely because people like Ron Graham
looked after him but but I would say not
at all odd in that he' found the thing
he loved which was doing math and if you
if you love that math maths that
much then any other Behavior would have
been odd so that that's the way I kind
of like in swimming he was in the pool
all the time because he just loved being
in the pool yeah the people that you
read about the ones that produce the
Pinnacle results by definition they are
unusual and that often manifest other
ways I think the other let's ask let ask
one
more uh that waving person yeah you I
was wondering is there any hope for
those of us who off or knocked off
orid from theic to the sublime the appro
found an interest later what if I was
good at the beginning and then I wasn't
good enough and now I'm still really
interested do I still have a prayer do I
still except that I wasn't really that
good yeah I think there's always a a
chance to restart the game because it's
such a logical subject you just have to
take yourself back to the point where
you know you understand and and start
again going down the path that uh
mathematicians have laid out for you so
I think if you've got determination and
this is why you know people carry on
doing mathematics however old they are
because theyve got a passion for wanting
to know the answer provided you've got
that passion doesn't matter when what
old what age you were when you started
if you want to know what the next step
is you'll be able to get there this is
one of the things that seems to be
determined about genius in general forms
is you see it with Newton and others too
the capacity to actually not leave your
desk for 24 hours independent of the
subject I was going to say that I think
the answer is a little like I wish I'd
learned another language when I was six
M it's a lot easier when you're six when
you're 36 so the chances that you will
learn it with the
fluency that you would have learned it
if you hadn't had the interruption of
zero but but the chance that you can
learn it to do it well enough for it to
be a source of great pleasure and
accomplishment that's a matter of
perseverance a good starting point is
Martin Gardner's books and recreational
math and that's a good way just to get
get into the swing of things and just to
learn some of the Cur math that's around
yeah and it's getting easier because of
the internet and the accessibility there
the Wikipedia resources actually
Wikipedia in mathematical areas is
really pretty darn good the higher up it
gets very reliable the materials and I
every week or so you know I go on NPR as
the math guy I get emails from people
with that very same question you can
reach people and we're not going to give
an hour's time in the response but we'll
say try this book or try to talk to this
person at your nearest university it's
actually relatively easy now you know if
you're a mathematician you actually your
heart lifts if someone says I'd like to
get back into mathematics we usually
spend a few minutes trying to help them
out we we have so few friends we need
everyone we can get uh two more and then
we'll yes over there yes you um I think
I don't know my experience is that when
I look at like a science textbook or
like physics or chemistry or something
that it's more like a story I can sort
of read it through and say okay get this
get that get that and then I look at
math and the you know starts out uh
let's assume this is a prime number you
get to the end and say well it's not
prime so this thing is false go wait did
we assume that three was a prime number
like I can't remember what the
assumption that would be so how do I
read a math textbook compared to
something like a physics the question is
if you read a science textbook it seems
like it's storytelling and you can get
involved and you get interested and you
want to know how it's going to turn out
you read a math textbook and you go into
it and they make assumptions and you
can't remember whether you made those
same assumptions and suddenly you are
brought to the end there's the answer
it's all to the comparison there would
be like reading a a cook book or an
automobile repair manual all four of us
have written books about mathematics
which tell the story that's why we're on
the stage of cost no but I I think even
the proofs that you find in in books you
know Fat's proof that every Prime uh
which has remained a one when you divide
it by four can be written as two squares
is a fantastic story and how you get
from you know something like 41 to 16 +
25 and whatever the prime is if it's got
remainder one on division by four you
can always write it as two squares is an
extraordinary story and I want I don't
want to just know the answer I want to
know how did this uh this hero get from
here to here see that's my suspicion
that the answer to your question is some
people like I once went to breakfast
with my boss Larry Tish at CBS and he
brought H Ross perau who was then just a
a tycoon and they they sat around and
they they opened up the Wall Street
Journal was at a breakfast table at the
Drake Hotel and they they looked at
these just sheets of numbers and they
would point and they giggled and they
gave a
little and like I guess we're going to
make him
numbers no I I but I thought to myself
wow these people read numbers the way I
would read ASAP you know it's just they
just are different
maybe I think
you're yeah she she can't make the steps
I think you're identifying a real
problem that
Marcus uh mentioned early on which is
that mathematical is a massive
mathematics is a very large scaffold and
and hierarchical and it's hard to learn
something before another thing and so
we've tended in writing textbooks to
look for very efficient very focused
proofs and kind of trust that the reader
knows why they want to be there and
that's not always a particularly good
solution the alternative and and uh a
mathematician called Moore in Texas
tried to do the opposite with great
students which is to motivate every step
prove nothing get the students to prove
everything for themselves and in theory
it was a fantastic idea in PR practice
it meant that by the end of a four-year
degree you were in semester
2 last that's the the tra the
evening
uh see I I hate to do the people in the
front is there somebody in the back yes
way in the back that's naked arm up
there
yeah um I want to go kind of back to
Kurt go Kurt Kur gell yeah I wonder if
you see his theorems as like a St rather
like a new opportunity to find maybe
Nona
map you going hear that the question is
because of gel's this uncertainty that
he
introduces oh boy am I going to have
trouble did you say non- aaic math yeah
yeah I
mean it's almost one of these things
what is mathematics because you can
Define mathematics and for many years it
was is the stuff that follows from the
axioms but most of what mathematicians
that are living today do do is actually
non-axiomatic
it's just exploring things in an
analytic way thinking rationally it's
not based on those axioms is this sort
of pure axiomatic mathematics that sort
of has a
history but if you just actually say of
all the people who earn money by doing
mathematics hardly any of them do acatic
mathematics they deal with problems that
arise in the real world or within
mathematics but not in an axiomatic
framework that was for acatic math or
was he uh dis in a sense girdle proved
that it was a pointless trying to do
that because he wasn't going to capture
everything have we s have we answered
your question yes thank you you're
welcome thank everybody for
[Applause]
[Music]
coming